want to play football professionally
absolutely
I woke up this morning before our events
trained
five six days a week I'm still up at 4
30 I go get my training in that passion
is still there and the ability is still
there he hasn't played professionally
since the
both solidarity and outrage why did you
choose that day and to protest in that
way that's actually something we're
going to dive deep into with the doc
that's coming this fall but as it
relates to the book people may look at
that moment and be like oh you must have
been this person all along it's like no
there's growth that has to happen will
you continue to sit yes then Kaepernick
couldn't get hired and even sued the NFL
for collusion in a case that's settled